the rules committee -- for
Monday March eighteenth
is hereby Cold War please
revise an audio and video
recording please Christine
is being made this all suite
of an eccentric please call
the roll fully here Cunningham
Carillo yeah flora Grayson
Maienschein Mathis quirk Silva
Ramos Ramos Wicks
here we have we have a quorum
we have a proposed consent
agenda --
is our motion to strike to
the consent agenda I would
respectfully ask that the
referral ACA one people from
okay so we will pull a see
a one that will be treated
as a separate matter is
our motion the remainder
of the consent agenda
-- by miss Carillo second
of a much we're almost --
Rivas park --
and -- match our trip is
cultural Cooley hi
Cooley aye Cunningham Cunningham
I. Carillo Carillo aye flora
for aye Grayson aye Grayson aye
Kamlager-Dove hi Kamlager-Dove
Brian Maienschein Maienschein
aye Mathis quirk Silva Ramos
right from us I riverside
riverside works time which I
okay very good and is there
a motion on her for all of a
CA one -- to local government
appropriations motion by
Mister Rommel seconded by
the store reverse thank you very
much -- that structure
please call the roll hi
Cooley I'd Cunningham
no Cunningham no Carillo
I Carillo I've flora so
flora no Grayson Grayson
aye Kamlager-Dove hi
Kamlager-Dove I am Maienschein
Maienschein aye Mathis no Mathis
know first so that Ramos right
Ramos I request request I works
Wicks motions pass
and the schools Quincy Jones